condenado a muerte el 6 de diciembre el
disidente iraní habits fue ahorcado este
sábado por la mañana según las
autoridades judiciales iraníes una
ejecución denunciada inmediatamente por
la Unión Europea y Suecia la pena de
muerte es un castigo inhumano e
Irreversible y Suecia como el resto de
la Unión Europea condena su aplicación
en cualquier circunstancia
verá el líder del movimiento árabe para
la liberación de haz un grupo
separatista considerado terrorista por
Teherán que opera en la provincia de
cusstán la región hogar de una
importante minoría árabe fue escenario
de protestas violentamente reprimidas en
2019 habib Chad fue acusado de perpetrar
un atentado mortal en 2018 su confesión
difundida en un vídeo por medios iraníes
fue probablemente obtenido bajo tortura
según grupos de Derechos Humanos el
opositor que vivía en Suecia fue
secuestrado en Estambul durante un viaje
privado en octubre de 2020 y permaneció
en cárceles iraníes desde entonces
11 personas sos de estar implicadas en
su secuestro fueron detenidas
posteriormente por las autoridades
turcas la ejecución de habib se produce
unos meses después de la del británico
iraní al iresa Bari condenado por
espionaje en los últimos meses las
condenas a muerte se han multiplicado en
el país en un contexto del aumento de la
represión tras las masivas
manifestaciones contra el gobierno el
pasado otoño en 2022 se produjeron 582
ahorcamientos según las organizaciones
de defensa de los Derechos Humanos